Okay in chapter 8 we are looking at the second technique of
breakthrough copy and that is identification and identification
Gene talks about as defining
and discovering the
roles that your Market wants to
play. So the the character roles like who they
want to be and their achievement roles what they want to achieve and
so once you spend time
understanding
who your Market wants to be what they want to achieve you can
then begin to draw that connection between those
aspirations and your your
product and your solution. So if we
start with the character who to who does
your your prospect who's your Market want to be? So then
the work here is you know, what are some of the characteristics that
your prospect wants others to
see in them? What was it they secretly desire
to be seen as and you hear
you're just gonna you just make some notes about what you know about
your Market based on your interaction based on your research.
And then this is another powerful question here.
So what is your prospect believe or what does he
want to believe about himself or herself? Obviously.
So, um, what are those
things that that they maybe do
believe or maybe they they don't quite believe it
about themselves. But if they believed it it would it would
make that character role true for
them because the maybe they have a set of beliefs that
once they, you know, become a certain
person. These These are the beliefs that
they'll have about themselves and increase confidence or you
know, being comfortable
around members of the opposite sex. For example
So then we move on to achievement roles.
And this is more about obviously what they want to achieve what
kind of status they want in life.
And so, you know here we're looking at
what status has your prospect already achieved in
society. So who who are they now? What is
their current status? And then what
status do they want to achieve? So this is
us if you picture somebody standing at the
edge of a cliff this is their current status
and then there's a Ravine and
then there's another cliff on the other side and that's
where they want to be. That's the status they want to achieve so
we have to figure out how do we bridge that
gap for them? And then here this next
section we're adding identification roles.
So describe the role that your product offers
to your prospect who does it help them
become so by using your product who can they
become who can they begin to identify as and
does it match up to what they want to achieve and who
they want to
Understanding your prospects person your products personality.
So this is something really interesting that Gene talks about
in the book that that every product has this
embedded or can have
this embedded personality into it. So there can be
different images that that associate with
with your product. You need
you think about some of the the old travel advertisements that
you may have seen and it's it's images
of freedom and you know sitting on the
beach with a drink with an umbrella in it.
Or it's the ability to to go and
explore, you know ancient ruins, but it's
it's this idea of complete freedom
and in almost
in a way maybe a superiority of being
able to have these experiences that other other,
you know normal people quote unquote can't have
so what kind of personality is
your is your product bringing to
your your prospect? So when your
product when you're Prospect thinks about your product or products
like yours, like what images are they thinking of in their
mind and then here, you know based only
on what your prospect sees or thinks about your product. Is there
a natural character role that that
he gets to step into after buying your products
you can use those images that maybe your prospect
has associated with product like yours
or your product and then is there is
there a connection between the
Character they want to be and the images that
they see in in your
product and here it doesn't like I said here. It doesn't matter if
you think your prospect is wrong that we're just
trying to understand their their perspective. So they may have
an image on your product that that you
disagree with and and that's okay
here. We're just collecting data.
So then is there a difference in the
image? You see in the image or Prospect sees? This is referring back
to this question. And then is there a logical link between
how your prospect sees your product the image
and the personality and the role that you've made
if if you only makes
a purchase so you've created this role for them to step into and
is there a logical link between
how they see your product and how you
want them to see your product Your solution and and
here you you get to describe that
connection so describe it below list The Logical
steps between the two because
Having a logical connection between
where your prospect is
how they see your your product and what your
product actually offers in the way. It speaks to your your prospect.
If it doesn't make sense, then
they're not going to take those steps to toward a
purchase. And so here's saying, you
know, if there's not a logical link between those those
two those two places what you're what your
prospect sees in your product and what
your product actually is and actually
does then you have to build that new
image onto your product so that
when you're Prospect sees it and and understands
what it is that you you're offering
them to be able to step into
this new achievement role this new character role that
it lines up with with what
they want. And you know, if it doesn't
then then your job is to
a better picture for them of showing them
that
that maybe they have an idea
in their mind that there's not
going to be beneficial for them like you you think you want this but what
you really want is this so there there can be some some little
bit of that kind of gets into redefinition which
we talk about in another another chapter when
we look at another break for advertising technique, so
So then when you need to build new images into
your product the process
for that is you're going to start by listing
the main image that your prospect has in his mind
about your product or just products like yours.
And then you start describing the image that
you that you want your prospect to see.
And and this is just getting very clear
on what is real and and in
the mind of your prospect and and what we want to
create in the mind of our market and Prospect. So the
difference between those two images is the gap
and we have to bridge that Gap. So this is
in this section here.
We get to the work of bridging that Gap. So we
start with the primary image the
character role in the belief that
your prospect sees when he thinks about your product.
And then we list some of the natural consequences the
consequences of that image in the
natural consequences of the character role
in the belief that they have.
And so you Gene says
you have to use the natural consequences to show your prospect the
natural path from where he is to what
he and what he believes to the new character and
achievement roles that await him once he
purchases your product. So
this this is the work of um,
it's almost like creating an instructions
for for your prospect
and by by just writing out
these instructions and even if
it's not done in a way that you would use use these
instructions as your copy just in your head as you
get clear on what your prospect needs
to believe to become the
person that they want to be the character and to
achieve the things that they want to achieve and those
achievement roles then sort of beginning to
match that with the image of your product and bridging
that Gap this this
will be an exercise that brings you
clearly and ultimately will
help you communicate effectively to to
your prospect and especially to prospects who
you just can't figure out why whether or not buying is because
there's a gap between
How they see your product and how they
see themselves and and you have
to help them see themselves differently or help them.
See your product differently.